daniel verger bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin alors en pleine
campagne électorale votre tribune pour
le pouvoir de vivre quel est le message
principal que vous en voyez aujourd'hui
le message principal c'est que
l'ensemble de nos organisations sociales
écologiques syndicats fondation mutuelle
donc des acteurs importants de la
société civile nous considérons
essentiel que le débat le débat de
société auquel appellent les élections
de 2022 soit un débat de qualité et un
débat vraiment orientée dans les 150
jours qui lui restent vers des sujets
majeurs pour une société qui soit plus
juste plus solidaire
plus démocratique aussi et qu'ils
puissent permettre d'accélérer la
nécessaire transition écologique et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
impliquons en proposant ses 90
propositions airs en proposant donc ce
projet un peu globale et cohérente pour
que ça fasse partie du débat et que ce
soit même au centre des discussions
quels sont selon vous les projets
majeurs pour cette campagne électorale
on doit en parler beaucoup de sécurité
notamment ces derniers jours
c'est une priorité selon vous
alors pour nous ce que l'on constate
c'est que les personnes sont beaucoup
plus demandeuses d'une société qui prend
soin qui protège qui accompagne qui
permet de vivre dignement qui accélèrent
aussi la transformation écologique dans
un souci de justice pour qu'elle soit
une bonne nouvelle pour tous
qui permet des investissements vers
l'avenir et qui aussi redonne de la
force ou projet démocratique dont qui
permettent à chacun de pouvoir
participer de pouvoir dialoguer il est
aussi partie prenante des décisions
c'est plutôt ça les sujets qui nous
semble important la lutte contre le
chômage buts pour le pouvoir d'achat
mais aussi plus globalement pour ce
qu'on appelle le pouvoir de vivre
c'est-à-dire cette capacité à être
ensemble dans une société acteur actrice
est reconnue aussi pour toutes les
contributions que l'on apporte il est
aussi le fait que vous déploriez que la
campagne tourne tourne plutôt autour de
l'immigration et de la sécurité
alors effectivement nous pensons que ces
sujets sont évidemment des sujets
importants que par exemple la meilleure
intégration des migrants est évidemment
un sujet extrêmement important il ya
aussi de vrais enjeux pour permettre que
les talents et les capacités des
migrants puissent être mieux employé en
donnant par exemple le droit de
travailler plus et plus largement mais
effectivement nous considérons que ils
peuvent aussi servir de l'écran de fumée
à d'autres sujets majeurs autour d'une
injustice sociale autour de de la
rénovation thermique des logements par
exemple autour du fait qu' il est
essentiel pour nous que l'on puisse
vraiment combattre le chômage en
particulier le chômage de longue durée
avec par exemple une garantie d'emploi
pour les chômeurs de longue durée de
façon à ce qu'ils puissent avoir un
emploi qui leur permettent de contribuer
comme ils le souhaitent à la société
c'est plutôt ça les sujets qui nous
semble devoir être mis en avant ainsi
qu'à un revenu minimum garanti qui
assure à tout le monde
50% de du revenu médian comme ressource
vous insistez un également sur la
transition écologique c'est quoi
finalement le lien avec la pauvreté
le lien avec la pauvreté c'est que et
bien en fait ce sont les plus pauvres
qui sont souvent les premières victimes
de les problèmes écologiques par la
mauvaise qualité de l'air qu'ils
respirent dans les quartiers par le fait
qu'ils sont dans des dans des logements
mal chauffés
et souvent insalubres et dont le
cameroun nous pensons qu'il y a un vrai
enjeu qui n'ont pas souvent la
possibilité de pouvoir se nourrir
le montre vos images comme ils le
souhaitent et avec des produits 100 donc
un vrai enjeu de renforcer des mesures
qui soient à la fois écologique et
sociale comme par exemple un plan massif
d'investissement dans là la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et en
particulier des logements étant
prioritairement des des passoires
thermiques
deuxièmement l'accès pour tous à des
tarifs sociaux dans les cantines avec
une fait de privilégier les filières bio
et de proximité avec le fait que la la
garantie d'emploi à partir d'une
approche territorialisée et donc d'une
mobilisation des territoires se
développera grâce à la mise en oeuvre d'
emploi beaucoup centrés sur eux sur les
liens sur l'accompagnement des personnes
mais aussi sur l'entretien de des
paysages et de la nature et qu'il ya de
vrai potentiel ainsi en développement
agro écologie également à faire en sorte
que cette transition écologique qui doit
s'accélérer soit en fait une une chose
positive pour les plus pauvres dernière
question emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer
demain il devrait aborder des questions
économiques notamment le contrat
d'engagement pour les jeunes de 500
euros peut-être aussi la réforme des
retraites vous en attendez quoi du chef
de l'état demain
nous attendons qu'ils contribuent à
cette élévation du débat nous attendons
aussi qu'il aille plus loin dans les
réformes engagées parce que le le
contrat peu d'engagement pour les jeunes
s'avèrent extrêmement décevant par
rapport aux projets qui étaient donc il
ya quelques mois encore y compris par
lui en juillet nous pensons que
l'engagement point jeunesse est un
aspect extrêmement important de du
projet que nous présentons mais aussi
des nécessités pour pour la société et
donc qu'il faut sans doute aller
beaucoup plus loin vers une nous nous
appelons par exemple à ce que ce revenu
minimum garanti soit ouvert aux jeunes
des 18 ans en fonction évidemment des
ressources
pour qu' il soit vraiment pris en compte
autant que comme que les autres adultes
et en prenant aussi en considération le
fait que les jeunes sont
particulièrement touchés par la pauvreté
merci beaucoup daniel verger d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
arte france je le rappelle vous êtes
responsable études et recherches au
secours catholique